Khloe Kardashian is shutting down  internet trolls weighing in on her  personal life what is wrong with people  after a Twitter user referred to Khloe  as passive when it came to her Instagram  posts and relationship with Tristan  Thompson the new mom who has kept quiet  since her boyfriends alleged cheating  scandal clap back writing you're  assuming you know who I'm talking about  and you're assuming you know my feelings  adding assuming anything is anything but  wisdom I love you pretty girl Khloe  keeps posting the most adorable photos  of true how she doing is there any yeah  really really really great yeah loving  being a mom any way we can get her back  in LA so you can have that grandbaby  we'll be back really soon still no word  on when Khloe will be leaving Cleveland  or the status of the reality stars  relationship with the NBA pro but Khloe  seems happier than ever with her little  girl true to be happy that comes from  within  you